connor one of our glassblowers
has got really nice demonstration
and the difference between so-called
borosilicate glass
the sort of glass that's used for
chemical apparatus
and quartz
which is silicon dioxide which is used
for very high temperature applications
like powerful street lights and things
like that and so what he did it's very
simple is to take a piece of either
quartz or borosilicate and heat it up
in a
oxygen gas
torch
that's a torch with natural gas methane
mixed with oxygen so it burns at a
higher temperature heat it up and then
plunge it into a beaker of water
cold water he started
with
heating borosilicate glass
which melts to make quite a large blob
at the bottom
and then as that is
dunked into the water all right connor
show us the business mate
several things happen
first of all of course the water begins
to boil but
there is a huge thermal gradient
difference in temperature between the
glass
that's outside the water and
the red hot lamp at the bottom
and this causes strains in the glass
so it cracks and the whole lamp falls
off
and that lamp is still
very hot on the inside but it's cooling
on the outside and
this difference in temperature creates
big strains because as things cool down
they contract
so the outside is trying to get smaller
and the inside
isn't contracting and
those
strains give rise to cracks and because
the heat takes time to come out of the
glass those cracks spread through the
glass relatively slowly
so you can watch them developing
and there are pings and so on as bits
fly off
this is rather different from
the so-called prince rupert's drop when
molten glass is poured into water
and you get a piece of glass which looks
okay
until you break a little bit off and
then it goes bang what is important if
you're a glass blower like connor
when you finish
you have to cool the glass slowly
or
you freeze
all these strains into the glass
and when somebody uses it
suddenly bang it's gone
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
some of you will have seen quartz as a
natural mineral you can get quite big
crystals
quartz
has a very small
coefficient of expansion you can heat it
to much higher temperature as you heat
it up
you can see
that
it starts glowing far more brightly than
the borosilicate glass
and then
when you plunge it into water
there's no strain so that or relatively
little so there's lots of bubbling and
flushing about but nothing crack well
when you heat
any material up
it tends to expand
this is why on hot days railway lines
stop buckling and trains can't run but
the amount that different materials
expand when you heat them
can vary very substantially metals
expand a lot so the quartz expands less
it expands very much less and the
strains that are generated
are much less than the strains needed to
break the material
in the borosilicate there is a big
contraction of the outside which is
being cooled by the water
whereas the inside is not contracting
because it's still hot but it was but
the quartz was still interesting when it
went in the water wasn't it what was
interesting
is that connor heated what was
effectively the open end of a quartz
test tube
so when he plunged it into the water
the gas inside the test tube was very
hot the air
and
as it cooled down
of course the gas
contracted as well
and it sucked up a whole lot of water
nearly half the volume of the tube so as
conor took it out the tube was full of
water or half full of water
unfortunately the surface tension
was not enough to hold all the water in
the tube so it started running out after
a little while
borosilicate glass contains quite a high
content of sodium
so when conor heats it
you can see
a strong orange glow from the sodium
that is essentially evaporating
from the
glass as it's being heated
it's the same color that you see in
old-fashioned street lights which gives
you this orange color
and this emission from sodium is very
intense so you don't need much sodium in
the vapor to give you this color
professor watching this gives me the
impression that quartz is a more robust
material than
borosilicate why isn't all glassware
made of quartz
quartz is much more difficult to
manufacture
and so you can get quartz glassware
but it's much more expensive
and for most applications
you don't really need it
and because
borosilicate is much easier to work you
can make much more intricate apparatus
from borosilicate than you can from
quartz
but if you have high temperature
applications particularly
high power bulbs
the bulbs in the old projectors
the
bulbs and street lights in
xenon
headlights in cars these are made from
quartz
because
with borosilicate they just would melt
and were not strong enough
then suddenly
and pieces of glass fly everywhere
it looks like out of the textbooks i
just can't believe that nature can make
anything quite so beautiful